hello there I'm Max Keiser this is the
Kaiser report why are you bugging why
you bug in well here are the bullet
points for those of you at home keeping
score cities are on fire
forty million unemployed in America GDP
to decline by 50% in the second quarter
the velocity of money is dead
small businesses are dead and Jay Powell
said chairman says this is fine is it
fine is it fun this is fine
hi you begin why you buggin well this is
fine you know
the only solution they seem to have over
and over is more money printing and the
Fed is at that again non-stop since 2008
really
feds Powell says Fed policies will
absolutely not lead to more income
inequality this is what he claimed last
week well cities across America were on
fire and notice that he said income
inequality
you know money printing does it causes
asset prices to increase and capital
gains to increase he didn't mention that
he didn't mention the wealth gap so I
did want to turn to a chart from pew and
it shows the share of US aggregate
wealth since 1983 to 2016 this is what
the Fed has been doing this is the upper
income went from having 60% of all
wealth in America back in 1983 to now
having 79 percent and is probably much
higher even now middle income has been
the huge collapse as you see down from
32 percent to 17 percent so they're
nearly cut in half well this is the
latest chapter in the global
insurrection against banker occupation
you know we saw it with Occupy Wall
Street there was a concerted effort to
talk about how Wall Street and the
Federal Reserve Bank are creating wealth
in income disparities and distorting the
economy and bankrupting the nation then
we had an uprising in Cairo we had an
uprising in Athens that we covered and
we've had uprisings all over the world
as part of the global insurrection
against bankers occupation and now it's
in the United States and the u.s. dollar
I guess is gonna have to be sacrificed
if there's gonna be any hope here the
thing is they are printing for everybody
for the entire world and there are only
at the moment fiat currencies so if you
disregard gold and you disregard Bitcoin
the like most people in the world don't
notice that of course the dollar is the
strongest of the
them all of all the Fiats currencies
because everybody is the reserve
currency so here's Jay pals
you know printing money for everything
here's his story right here fed bought
three billion dollars in ETFs in May
junk bond holdings here include Hertz
JCPenney Neiman Marcus and whiting
petroleum because of course they do
lol nothing matters so you know they
basically bought the bags off huge
private equity and hedge funds that
otherwise would have perhaps closed the
gap in the wealth gap between those
wealthiest of Americans and the poorest
but they bought the bags off the likes
of you know Carl Icahn and Warren
Buffett these sort of people the
billionaires right I mean the standout
on that list would be Hertz so Hertz was
heading into bankruptcy for a year now
and just before they did declare
bankruptcy the central bank buys a bunch
of Hertz stock and you know to give some
back up to Carl Icahn the private
investor of private equity guy this
reminds me of the ECB funding for the
Louis Vuitton entrepreneur made a huge
purchase recently and that was all
funded by the European Central Bank of a
private company so the the private banks
if they're buying junk corporations and
they're actually buying an ETF with the
ticker symbol J & K which stands for
junk that means that we've kind of
crossed over to it into a no there's no
turning back now because the Fed its
balance sheet of approximately seven
trillion dollars and it's adding maybe a
trillion dollars every 7 to 10 days the
resale value of everything on the books
there is zero I mean you can't obviously
resell hurt stock because it just went
bankrupt a few days ago so that's
clearly worth zero everything on the
junk ETF is zero Blackrock that sells
the ETFs is charged with buying ETFs for
the Fed so the Fed and the government is
told Blackrock by ETFs those
that you sell for us with the government
with the printed money that were
printing okay that's obviously
corruption at the highest level and it's
horrible economics the bonds they might
convert to equity which apparently the
feds not supposed to own so you know the
but that they did not buy the actual
shares and hurts but they have these
junk bonds which there's confusion out
there whether or not it converts the
equity and now they own equity which
they say if I'm not supposed sone but
the people are always so smarter right
let's look at the with the people on the
other end of all of this free money
printing you know what they really think
of all this money printing people are
mistaking stimulus payments for junk or
scam mail no they're not mistaking it it
is junk
it is scam it is junk this is this is
scam let that be a lesson to you money
printing eventually comes to an end and
the only thing that you hear is the
jammed money printer and then you're
wondering where's my food where's my
government where where am i and you know
I'm sorry but I I have to ask what was
that last point you made that the people
of the United States of America are
receiving these debit cards like taken
by by this flotilla of cash yeah the
peep the government is sending the
United States citizens debit cards were
loaded with cash and they just assume
it's chunk and they're throwing in the
garbage and well it is John you know it
is this should be thrown in the garbage
there's no difference between the
plastic ETF card or you know a ATM card
loaded loaded with fiat money from the
government in those trash bags full of
Venezuelan boulevards you see on YouTube
now people are just carting away trash
bags full of Venezuelan bolivars all
fiat money for 300 years has gone has
lost 90% or more of its value it's
called garbage garbage
[Laughter]
this is all fine so let's look at the
headlines about this alleged no wealth
and income gap being created by a can
Tilian sort of effect that is happening
in the United States this non-stop since
2000 really when we officered all of our
creative capital all our industrial
capital to China since we allowed
derivatives trading to happen the
explosion and that the and we ended
glass-steagall let's look at some of the
data here that shows otherwise
- what j-pal asserted this is what
happens when predominantly workers with
low salaries lose their jobs average
salaries go up so here's a year on your
change of the average hourly earnings of
employers so going back years and years
and years hourly wages have just soared
why well because this is hourly wages so
this is not the transfers from the
government yet in this data what this
shows is that all the low-income workers
got laid off now you have just all of
the white-collar workers all of the
people in New York City and San
Francisco and Los Angeles and places
like that
still have their job they're able to
work remotely from home oh yeah this is
remarkable that these hourly wages
suddenly skyrocketed because of the
money giveaways from the feds and it
shows that up until that moment the
average worker hourly wages were below
subsistence right people are working
below subsistence wage levels they have
to they're living in their car and
they're working under minimum wage and
they work two or three jobs and so a
cash injection from the government
suddenly spikes that hourly wage it
proves that they're living in America on
a subsistence wage which is just one
notch above slave wages right their
slave wages then they're subsisting
wages and that's where America is at 200
million Americans and subsistent wages
we're gonna get to that data right now
because incomes for all Americans beyond
the hour those who are still working and
now in getting paid by their jobs their
incomes have gone up as I showed in the
last chart they've gone up about 5%
because they got rid of they fired all
the other workers but all those people
who fired are now represented in this
chart these are the people that are at
home they're not working they're
collecting unemployment benefits but are
now called enhanced unemployment
benefits so they're making 600 extra
dollars a week that shows up in this
data u.s. incomes for all Americans rose
by 10.5% in April on the heels of
enhanced unemployment benefits the
expectation was for a 5.9 percent
decline so how do we ever get out of
this situation where Jay Powell is
printing his money he's giving it away
the government is borrowing money and 3
trillion this quarter alone that's
caused wages to go up this is end of
empire kind of stuff this is bread and
circuses and it's really really hard to
end bread and circuses once you start
right well the primary component in fiat
money the US dollar is cotton so America
is gonna get back to cotton pickin right
that's it cotton pickin is gonna be
number one employee to feed that money
printer in Washington money printer
Gober there's Jay Powell he's in the big
house looking out over the cotton
pickers pick me some more cotton so I
can print some more fiat Americans like
ok will do well the Fed is if you are
looking for a job and your unemployment
your enhance unemployment benefits are
not good enough for you here the Fed is
still hiring apparently so these are the
sectors in the economy in the United
States still hiring only a few of the
hundreds of track categories added jobs
last month so this is for April
warehouse clubs and super centers so if
you're working at Amazon or Walmart
there are plenty of jobs available
central bank's number two
adding jobs so it takes a lot of effort
to apparently print that I guess I could
be employed I could start working part
part time jump down turn around pick the
manicott
yeah baby let's do it and finally
Americans are doing something surprising
with their money right now Gretchen
Howard CEO of Robin Hood describes a
spike in deposits of twelve hundred
dollars and two thousand four hundred
reflecting the amount and stimulus many
individuals and couples received during
the week of April 13th
so people are again bread and circuses
they love joining the speculative bubble
and they also along with Fed the Fed
buying all these junk bonds they were
buying Warren Buffett's bags they were
buying Stanley Druckenmiller sh bags
they were buying Carl ikons bags he
don't hurt guess who was buying it was
Robin Hood apps people with the free
free money for the Fed the Fed knew
you're gonna give it to Carl Icahn and
Warren Buffett and Chuck and Miller to
exit right well it turns out the Fed is
the dumb money that's our money oh we're
so dumb all right we're gonna take a
break thing when we come back much more
coming your way
welcome back to the Kaizen report on Max
Keiser time now to go to Tyler Lynn dome
he is the representative for Wyoming
house district 0-1 for those outside of
America Wyoming is not only the most
bitcoins friendly state in America it's
also the tenth largest state in the
Union and the least populated it's born
for social distancing all right Tyler
welcome to the Kaiser report yeah thanks
for having me really appreciate the
opportunity now many people were here
Wyoming and think not only Yellowstone
National Park ranching farming with the
Cova 19 pandemic we saw livestock
destroyed while supermarket shelves were
empty what caused this and what
legislation did Wyoming introduce to
address this Tyler I think the first
thing that we should make very clear
though is the corona buyers did not
cause the collapse itself of the meat
supply chain meat supply chain was
always pretty horrible it was a
centralized mess of kind of propping up
for big monopolies and that's where
everybody gets their meat whether it's
from the back of a beef track or from
your grocery store whatever it's all
going through these four big outfits and
so the coronavirus was essentially just
a straw that broke the camel's back well
Wyoming did and we inadvertently good
timing on our parts I've been working on
this issue for over right around six
years and what I did is I drafted a
piece of legislation that took advantage
of the federal Meat Inspection Act the
federal Meat Inspection Act says that
all meat sold in the United States for
retail has to go through a USDA packing
facility and so in the state of Wyoming
we wheat what we did is we fractionalize
cattle we said that you can you can sell
shares on an animal or you can sell
shares on an entire herd of animals and
that way that share grants you access to
those animals without going through all
of the red tape and regulations and
inspection processes all of those things
that add quite a bit of cost and also
put more money in the Packers pocket so
Wyoming is really taking on some great
initiatives and put some
legislation in place and particularly in
the Bitcoin space you have been a huge
proponent at Bitcoin and have helped
pave the way for Wyoming to become the
crypto friendly state in America why
well it's all about that centralization
I mean nobody likes centralization right
centralized government centralized money
centralized meat supply chains and so I
became a big fan of Bitcoin and
blockchain technology back in O I first
learned about it back in 2012 from the
Ron Paul forums and I really studied
down on it and so when we when I got
going in the legislature I realized
there were some issues in the state of
Wyoming as far as how our laws were
constructed and we were actually one of
the worst in the nation for Bitcoin our
money transmitter transmitters license
was blocking any exchange for taking on
Wyoming customers we were able to fix
that and then we just kicked it up a
gear now we've passed right around 20
pieces of legislation that handle
everything from security law to banking
law to a lot of those different aspects
that have stood in the way from
essentially this currency going
industrialized and being able to really
be utilized by individuals even even not
it's not so much mainstream individuals
but more of you were you know average
folks that may not necessarily even know
what Bitcoin is this is an opportunity
for them because it's much more
mainstream now in the state of Wyoming
right now I oming you know that a
message of individual sovereignty seems
to fit in with the ethos of Wyoming and
the Wyoming state motto is equal rights
now it was the first state to give women
the right to vote out of necessity
Wyoming needed the votes to gain
statehood and you know this is part of
the interesting dynamic in the United
States between the states and the
federal government so these two are
competing with each other on some level
and could the same thing happen for
Bitcoin in other words you looked at the
American states and you said you know
there's a state out there called
Delaware and it gets a lot of business
by being the number one state that
companies incorporate in why don't we do
that and be the Delaware for Bitcoin why
can't Wyoming be the destination for
Bitcoin and now this is exactly what
you've done my
question is could the same thing happen
for Bitcoin where other states see your
success in this hyper and deflationary
necessity as the federal government
paper money collapses the states and by
the way in the Constitution I believe it
says this only the states can create
money the states take it upon themselves
to preserve America Tyler what do you
think yeah absolutely that's not gonna
home run and that's exactly what we're
chasing down it's all about economic
development it's our it's all about
making sure there's this safe spot to
land for these types of tech companies
and also an area that they can flourish
and so as states realize that their fiat
currency is being devalued and their
purchasing power is going in the toilet
I think there's gonna be a lot of a lot
of state governments and a lot of and
maybe even smaller governments that
start turning towards different types of
assets to protect their wealth and just
like individuals have done and so while
it's definitely leading the way in there
in that cause but but it's important to
remember that we are nowhere close to
even being done we're still full steam
ahead we're looking at some really
interesting stuff right now in regards
to the banking secrecy act as as far as
know your customer and anti money
laundering laws and so I think we're
gonna have something fun for next year
that really should put things on set on
that note the Wyoming legislature has
just formed the Select Committee on
blockchain and financial technology are
you a member what are the plans for
Wyoming in terms of FinTech and Bitcoin
yeah I definitely am a member you know
we had the task force before and where
we were a little different than like
other states have task force's we were
different in regards we actually do
things and actually accomplish things so
we were very successful we moved it on
to being a select committee so we could
sponsor our own legislation and we could
do even more
we expanded who could be on it and I
myself am a member were chaired the
chairman of that committee our chairman
Jared Olson out of Cheyenne Wyoming and
chairman Chris Roth was out of Laramie
Wyoming both great individuals and of
course we've got Kaitlyn long on that on
that committee Kaitlyn long certainly
has been a huge fire starter in this
area of
getting Bitcoin to the masses using the
existing infrastructure because she has
that incredible background on Wall
Street in the banking sector and she's a
very high-level executive and she kind
of defected over to the Bitcoin space
and I know Wyoming is now ripe to become
the destination for Bitcoin based
startups are you seeing that already our
Bitcoin based startups moving to Wyoming
when we first started this whole journey
and started our little task force we had
people showing up to our meetings
without shoes on and just kind of some
wild cats now the folks that we got
showing up are very much suit and tie
and kind of OGIS in this space we've got
car that I owe HK is now a mal Wyoming
business we take a lot of testimony from
folks like consensus and crack and then
those types of folks and so yeah they're
coming they're here already
IOH kay just dropped a half a million
dollars on the University of Wyoming to
to help with their their blockchain lab
so that's it's it's happening and if
you're not in Wyoming yet you're gonna
miss the boat sticking with Kaitlyn long
she's gone ahead and started a bank can
you give us the details on that what's
the status where is that how's that
doing to be honest with you I kind of
once once the legislations in place I
kind of take a step back and let them
work out their business and how things
are gonna move forward last night I
talked to Kaitlyn though she said things
were moving well and that they were they
were getting close you know there's
probably there's probably a total of
eight entities right now they're looking
at starting up their their their own
banks in the state of Wyoming in regards
in regards to digital assets and all of
those guys are moving full steam ahead
I've got you know I I think I think a
couple are probably gonna finish towards
the top but it's it's it's fun to watch
because we didn't spend as a state any
money on attracting these businesses we
took a very unconventional route
compared to how other states view this
economic diversification we just set
legal precedents we were smart and we
sat down and we studied the laws and we
figured out how we can actually move the
laws in such a manner that still
provides consumer protection but at this
same time is inviting to business and so
far so good it's been successful now I
want to return to kind of this state
versus federal government tension or the
existence of this because it's a checks
and balance it's built into the American
system of governance to have a little
many many checks and balances the
various you know houses of government
and also between the governors of States
and the President of the United States
and so when you're talking Bitcoin to
people in Wyoming right they're not from
Silicon Valley they're not financed ears
Wyoming as we said at the top of the
show is mostly about agriculture and
ranching and if you know correct me if
I'm wrong here I might be stereotyping
what's going on there but that's my
perception but isn't isn't the urgency
in the pitch isn't it about self
sovereignty and it isn't it about hard
money and the fact that the federal
government you know needs to be kept in
in check Tyler that's right it's all
about the Tenth Amendment it's all about
state sovereignty it's all about you
know keeping ours our citizens in our
state in a safe place regardless of what
Congress does because let's be very real
about this Congress is incompetent what
they're what they're currently doing
right now is there's a hot hot mass of
any kind of reaction that they're that
they're doing and whether it's in
regards to coronavirus or the
Meatpacking deal all of it's a hot mess
they could fix the Meatpacking deal with
with legislation that just D regulates
and let's state step set their own
course and it would cost nothing for
them to do that but instead they're
gonna do this whole pump and dump scheme
into ranchers across the West turn every
Rancher and in the West and to see it
into CRP farmers and it's just an
absolute wreck so when we're talking
about state versus federal we've really
stretched our legs in regards to crypto
currencies but we've also stretch their
legs in regards to gold and silver also
in the state of Wyoming gold and silver
is considered legal tender I was a
co-sponsor of that piece of legislation
and and and so you constantly see why
are they doing these things and it's
because we want to separate ourselves
from the some of the horrible mistakes
they're being made
the federal government we don't really
want to be associated though please guys
there quite a bit
wait wait wait one minute there gold is
legal tender in Wyoming holy mackerel I
was on the fence now I'm heading to I
oming how hard is it to master riding a
horse
you know I to be honest with you it's
one of those things that when we're when
we're talking about these self
sovereignty type type of concepts with
the state of I am and we do those things
for breakfast right I mean it's it's
normal day of course for us but in other
states there's such wild concepts and
it's it's kind of I don't know I
it's wild for me to hear about the
regulatory schemes at other states put
in place to somehow control their their
their citizens and in this video I oh
man we just want to leave people alone
so if you're not here like I said max if
you're not here you're gonna miss the
boat it's time to move so you're very
graciously avoided the question of how
long it would take me to learn how to
ride a horse
I guess because it doesn't seem like
it's even possible
thanks so much Tyler I'm filled with
confidence now all right no only joking
thanks for being on the show it sounds
fascinating we'll check in with you
again soon thanks for being on Kaiser
report
thank you all right well that's gonna do
it for this edition of the Kaiser report
with me max Kaiser and Stacy Herbert
want to thank our guest Tyler lindholm
he's over in the Wyoming House of
Representatives you want to get in touch
with us on twitter it's Kaiser report
until next time it's bye y'all
you
[Music]